if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you'd like them to watch and
why oh my god that's that's a such a
hard question what am i supposed to say
to that um
pick your favorite i'm joking
um
what do i want them to see and why oh
god
i mean
i don't have a favorite but i would say
maybe
angry goes west just because that was
really like
such a baby of mine that film and
i'm just i don't i'm proud of all the
movies that i've
been in and done but i don't know that
to me was was like the first time that i
really like came into my own as a
producer
and i i felt very
from and from the beginning to the end
of that movie like i just yeah that
movie is special to me
it's awesome
and dirty grandpa because everyone wants
to see me you know make out with de niro
for two hours
um
absolutely a hundred percent uh i love
ingrid goes west um so jumping into why
i get to talk to you uh so one of the
things about guy is first of all thank
you for the entertaining me last night
uh this was the movie i needed it's a
lot of fun
thank you um
one of the things about guy that is so
unique is how much he is changing things
on the day on set and i'm just curious
what was it like for you working with
him
and experiencing his sort of you know
spontaneity
um it was exhilarating to say the least
you know of course this you know the
script was there the script was fun um
so we kind of knew you know we had a
vague idea of
what was going to happen but i learned
very quickly that on a set with guy
ritchie you know you never know what's
going to happen because he he loves to
kind of you know get everybody together
in the morning
huddle up and and and rewrite scenes
come up with new ideas come up with new
jokes and stuff so for me it was kind of
it was a dream come true because i came
from an improv background i mean i love
i love beautifully written scripts and i
love saying my lines but i also i also
you know really like the kind of
you know almost athletic kind of energy
that he brought to the to filmmaking
where it was like you know you got to
get your jokes in you got to get your
pitch in you know because we're rolling
and uh so it was it was it was it was
fun and very appropriate for for for an
action
thriller because it almost felt like
that you know every day it felt like
energized like no one knew it was going
to happen you could just be thrown into
a scene i mean there was one day that i
think he came up to me he was like how
do you feel about uh singing a little a
little song
or beret strawberry strawberry aubrey
which is what he used to call me
and i'd be like i'm sorry you'd like me
to sing he'd be like yeah he's like
here's here's a song you know i'll see
you in 10. and it was like that kind of
thing so it was fun
i
can't imagine that uh i can't imagine
that especially it's one thing to act
it's another thing to sing on i
can't imagine yeah just just yeah sure
i'll just sing a little song for you
whatever you want guy he works with a
lot of the same people again and again
um and i'm just curious how did he how
did you connect with him
were you looking to do something with
guy like were you surprised he reached
out
i you know we
we
i was i was set up on a meeting with him
on a zoom meeting during the lockdown
you know and so i met him
just like this on screens and it was
really just a
a preliminary meeting you know and i
think it was more to like see if he
liked me or whatever and i kind of knew
that going into it of course i wanted
the i wanted the job i just i just
wanted it very badly um i thought the
meeting went went well i found out oh
maybe he's going to meet with some other
people and then that's when i went in
for the for the kill and i just
aggressively
uh and i'm not ashamed to say it i
aggressively just went at him and said
you absolutely must hire me
um
you know i'm i'm i'm i'm the man for the
job i'll get it done i'll be funny i'll
kick people's ass i'll do whatever you
want me to do so just hire me and then
he did
without questioning it he just said all
right fine um and so i think we started
off on a very
we're very much on the same page but i
would say i definitely you know i i
wanted it and i i went for it
were you brave enough to challenge him
to a game of chess
no no
definitely not i'm terrible at things
like that
well uh he's also kind of talented at
chess so definitely yes
we i would say we played mental chess
every day
we played we had our own little games
that we would play but
i didn't i didn't bother with the chess
so much
how much fun did you have shooting
there's a there's a sequence in the
movie where you're in a classic mustang
you're you're firing a gun outside the
window
um and i'm just curious how much fun you
had filming that sequence
i mean that that day was the very last
day of the shoot for me i had been there
for three months
i was waiting for that day i mean i want
you know i'm in an action movie it's
like give me some
give me some action so i kept um you
know because my character was
more of the kind of tech genius
you know dealing with the hacking into
the whatever um so i was really excited
to like you know get my weapon and and
get in there um it was scary you know
josh josh hartnett um who fancies
himself a stunt driver
um
you know and he he is was whatever to a
certain
extent but um but he was really driving
the car and we were whipping around
these cliffs and um it was dangerous so
there's an element of fear
and uh i will say you know i i am driven
by by fear motivated by
fear survival there so
some of it felt real and then you know
when i got to like do the actual scent
with this stunt driver doing the little
donuts and me shooting out the other
thing it was it was awesome i was like
more i you know they didn't even want me
to get to get out of the window
originally i was just gonna have my arm
shooting through the through the window
and i just begged them like please let
me get all the way out there
and they let me do it so it was cool
how much fun did you have trying to get
jason and hugh to break during scenes
was it like was it a mission or do you
know what i mean
i mean i didn't really mess around with
hugh so much you know he was doing his
little thing that he does but um
but
jason i had a lot of fun messing around
with he has a really good sense of humor
and he
you know he's always he's always joking
around too it was really funny to kind
of watch him transform into
to his horse and fortune you know sp spy
spy character because five minutes
before he'd be joking around making
stupid jokes with me um
but yeah i mean i was always going at
him you know and i would and i would do
things like you know say a line and then
slap his ass really hard and
guy would come up to me in between the
takes and go you know i
liked the bit where you
slapped his ass and maybe you could do
that again
and i'd be like yes sir
um so it was
it was fun it felt like we were just you
know
trying to take the piss out of each
other as all the british people say
um and
yeah
uh my last question
last question um i'm a big fan of mike
white and obviously loved white lotus um
with when when you got approached for
season two do you even ask for scripts
are you sort of like i trust mike
oh no i trust mike completely i've been
obsessed with mike for years and years
and years um
you know
chuck and buck was a huge inspiration
for angry goes west one of my all-time
favorite independent films ever made and
so mike and i you know we've actually
been the past couple years been trying
to collaborate on something so this is
this is kind of yeah this is like our my
my shot really to work with him so no i
don't i don't need to see anything that
he writes i think everything he does is
brilliant so
i'm i'm i'm along for the ride
on that note i got to say thank you so
much for your time great speaking with
you i wish you nothing but the best
thanks steve